l'abattoir au québec et ça énorme
l'idée des stades avec trente mille
personnes par ici mais il ya aussi et
aussi leur contexte ces espèces de fêtes
estivales d'été quoi ou à lyon raconte
upa 50 60 personnes sur un show ou alors
on fait il est arrivé où on a fait des
spectacles en plein centre de la ville
de québec puisqu'on parle du québec où
on l'a rencontrée chez moi 45000
personnes
ouais mais
et un espèce de magie où on arrivait que
les motos comme ça j'ai mélangé si tu
veux un peu limite qui mena les enfants
avec le fric tout le monde à l'heure
allemande par deux poumons tellement le
choix j'en ai tellement ou alors on
oublie ou apparaît alors en 79 berger
blâmant d'enfants sont proposés
starmania
oui tu as refusé m'a dit qu'est ce que
c'est cette formule du musical français
teddy réforme
ouais ça correspondait pas tellement à
l'époque cgt j'habitais berceville
woodstock dans l'état de new york et
j'avoue que je m'éclate et un peu mieux
tu vois à faire une espèce de musique
complètement craqué plutôt que de faire
des comédies musicales
j'ai fait tellement été un enfant de
l'école du spectacle de la rue ouais y'a
pas voulu non pas vraiment par contre
est venue à paris enregistré le vouvoyer
businessman oui parce qu'à l'époque
j'avais reçu donc un téléphone qui m'a
fait de faire cette chanson je vais
demander vous voulez me les envoyer
comme une histoire qu un petit monde i
know me vient à paris ça tombait bien
les besoins de soins des bacs j'suis en
écoute et ça m'a plu c'est une chanson
qui va beaucoup plus donc j'ai eu
beaucoup de plaisir à l'enregistrer
maintenant c'est devenu un tube énorme
en plus parfois au canada.la bord c'est
un hymne national exagéré mais c'est
quand même la section je sais que
j'aurai très détaillé
à tel point d'ailleurs qu'ils ont jamais
fait la régie mois plus tard manière et
7 juin à bamako 82 tu as eu des
problèmes
leur faire dire oui ça m'est arrivé à
plusieurs années la nuit comme de
grandes maisons à 90 a donné un peu plus
cher reste avait fait mais je disais oui
je me suis trouvé à la mauvaise place au
mauvais moment
ouais et donc ce que j'ai fait je me
suis fait prendre ces idiomes il n'ya
seulement une chose qu'on peut pas faire
dans la drogue c'est certain ouais mais
tu t'es fait prendre déjà consommé de
rien mais non non ils disent beaucoup ça
dépend qui en est on a un peu fait un
espèce d'exemple public
ah ouais c'est plus cher on prenait
beaucoup beaucoup
j'avais fait quelques pas dans un sens
c'est peut-être été une espèce de bouée
de sauvetage malgré moi ouais enfin que
que ce truc me soit arrivée ça nous a un
peu sauvé les way ça fait envie à lui
avait commencé je prendrai mon salaire
ne seront pas vous voyez des choses qui
pour moi de son modèle mais cela plaira
j'avais commencé comme une héroïne de la
copie est de mélanger
oui du sprint a donné beaucoup beaucoup
et finalement je pense qu'a rendu à
cette quantité là c'est plus très drôle
évidemment c'est une espèce de renouveau
merveilleux le football que j'ai fait si
on considère qu'un de ses amis quand
même certainement de revenir de tout ça
mais ça a provoqué des ratés dans ta
carrière c'est-à-dire ailleurs par
exemple on attendait sur scène d'arriver
en retard par exemple à cause de ça non
je crois que je pense que je pense que
j'en al-erian c'est pas très préoccupée
par la carrière je m'étais jamais été un
orage et arriviste du métier maintenant
d'ailleurs mangel encore beaucoup le
choix même si je suis plus un drogué et
encore j'ai quand même gardé ses côtés
patron de m'en [ __ ] mais de deux jeux
pour moi la liberté l'âge est la chose
la plus importante au monde
c'est pourquoi pendant ces deux ans là
j'ai écrit ces fabuleux s'agit
finalement de se dire j'ai fermé la
porte à clé ouais ils n'ont pas on va
enfermer que les peintres nombreux dans
la cellule comme on n'est pas beaucoup
avant on est touché ça au canada faisait
tout seul sur deux ans
si on passe quinze jours alors l'or fait
sangle c'est l'écouté radio j oui alors
justement parlons groupe ira petit que
c'est vrai qu'il a fait une année risque
j'ai donné au sida
c'est quoi une thérapie de groupe c'est
un peu base et si on veut sûr j'ai très
anciens comme comme méthode peut-être il
ya un endroit qui s'appelle d'étape à
new york en plein centre d'appel mis au
point par la vitre par la fenêtre
tu vois tu vois des john key dans le
parc ouais pendant que toi tu es entré
se désintoxiquer alors c'est assez
génial
comme école famille combien de temps
pour désintoxiquer la main au génie je
crois qu'après quatre mois c'était quand
même assez nette
mais jamais quand même fait deux ans
ouais je l'espère décision d'arrêter en
toile parce qu'en tant il serait très
facile à mettre plus qu'à l'extérieur
ah bon oui bah au début un peu donc sans
doute que tu as décroché en wi fi g pas
choisie coûterait très cher a aussi
haussé 4,5 fois plus cher qu'à
l'extérieur et l'approbation c'était
quoi après mais l'approbation elle est
encore n'a d'ailleurs pas non parce que
l'approbation n'avez pas le droit de
quitter annonçons real n'ont jamais
demandé aux états unis avant à part cela
prend à rêver mais là les drogués
canadien endroits de la vallée du lot si
on doit devenir enfin je sais pas c'est
comment c'est pas drôle par le
journaliste a effectivement je suis à
lorient on était sa huitième en serbie
mais c'est une expérience fabuleuse g
propre où j'ai pas vécu ça si tu veux
avec amertume jeunes en bout de tout ça
j'ai rencontré d'abord des gens qui ont
vécu des choses beaucoup plus dur que
moi et ça a été quelque chose de
fabuleux
une fois que j'ai terminé évidemment
parce que pendant votre vie c'est un peu
du même mois c'est pas c'est tout ce que
je vois c'est vraiment le choix de la
personne
l époque où ton poli tu vas laisser du
temps aux oignons
wyatt idéaux engagé disques d'or et de
platine millions passée alors sa
faiblesse du businessman avec des
nouveaux musiciens c'est quoi c'est
qu'on n'a pas une autre approche ici
c'est complètement autre chose
c'est vraiment quelque chose de plus il
sent que c'est plus flou joie ouais
c'est beaucoup plus mon concept aussi
j'ai un peu dans ceux ci que je me
faisais déjà dans les spectacles tôt il
faut dire que dans le contexte de la
comédie musicale c'est quelque chose
d'assez statique très dur comme ça qui
m'a avec le personnage je pense que le
disque va donner beaucoup plus un côté
émotion et plus et vicois au public
dégradé tout ouais ouais mais en volume
c'est ce qu'a fait jean françois est
aussi le guitariste de richard le
village de majuky du monde j'aime
comment a par ailleurs la danse dans une
espèce de tour
c'est spécial le concorde lafayette mais
je me sens comme un jeu je glisse c'est
comment tu fais pour trouver de la doc à
paris alors je regarde les autres
ouais facile non pas les messages à se
voir gamme is in the garden